[Music]  thank God your presence graces the air  and soon everyone Aussie high-reward  yes hi it takes nothing special to mop  up after the dyeing you're prettier than  last one to save a soul has quite  something less Amanda's body and well as  her mind but she's shrouded in darkness  [Music]  when you pray and you get a response  just like he's physically in me it's how  he guides me my little Saviour  [Music]  hey what you up to a private parent  you're still nursing well I know what  happened oh the good girls good Oh cuz  even got her so I just want to see you  loosen up I've got more important things  on my mind him  isn't real  nothing worthwhile comes easy to do you  must be the loneliest girl I've ever  seen I'm ready and open  I feel full of your love than ever  before oh yes of course  what if I'm getting it all wrong all the  good girls gold  [Music]